so i want to start with i think the most
important question
um obviously this is an amazing project
getting to work with these amazing
people and ryan
um i i guess my big question is um how
much ultimately did you pay to be in the
movie
that is a really good question honestly
you know i would have paid any amount of
money
to be in the company of these folks and
to do this still
a hundred percent you know yes 100
so i am curious um when did you actually
find out that you had landed the role
and did all the people around you when
you found out think that you were a
crazy person
because you screamed so loud
yes so it was um it was august of
2019 um and i
so i had auditioned a month before but i
hadn't really heard uh
much you know for a while and then i had
a screen test
with my co-star ariana dubose and
when i saw her name on the sign and she
like i
was floored she is a broadway icon and i
could not believe that i was gonna get
to do this
screen test this chemistry read with her
um
and it went really well but i just was
like okay i just have to
i just have to hope and then live my
life and then the next day
i got the call while i was thrift
shopping in bushwick brooklyn
and here we are right i
did you let out a scream or did like
what was that you know what i mean
i it was a lot of like
oh my goodness oh my gosh like i
actually i do have a picture of
um i when i got the call and so
i will always remember that but i was
literally like ah
i couldn't believe it and the first
person i called was my mom um
but she didn't pick up so then i called
my grandma and then it turns out my mom
was at my grandma's house so they got to
hear the news together
so that is that is amazing um i love
ryan's commitment to uh diversity
and inclusion both in front of and
behind the camera
this is another one of those projects
that champions that um can you sort of
talk about what it means to you to be a
part of something like this and
with his commitments oh absolutely i
feel like
it is the greatest joy to be able to
bring my full self
my full identity to a role and to not
only be
accepted but celebrated and ryan has
made such a commitment
of of hiring diverse and inclusive
talent
and in the kinds of projects that he
develops
i am so grateful that we have a
visionary like ryan
uh in our creative world oh i'm all in
on this
um i definitely want to get specific and
talk about i love the finale
that number is fantastic i want to know
what was it like actually filming that
um and can you sort of talk about like
the prep that went into that
oh my goodness yes um as far as just
like
dance so on on my own like dance wise we
had been
rehearsing that number for i want us
like that was one of the first numbers
that we learned and we it was also one
of the last numbers that we shot so
we had been working on it for a while um
and when it came time to shoot it i
don't think i could have
you know you can never prepare for
something like that because you have all
of the background actors and all of the
dancers and all the principal cast
they're just like cheering each other on
i remember before
every take we would like sort of like do
like a hyped circle and just get people
pumped
because every single take had to be full
out and
even though it was you know they were
long days we were all so happy to be
there and i will never forget
um when we finally wrapped on our last
day
everyone no one wanted to leave and we
all sort of
got in this like big group hug mosh pit
and someone started playing we are the
champions over the sound speaker
and we were all singing along and
hugging and it literally was like the
high school football team won the state
championship it was magical
uh you and james uh have fantastic
chemistry together
i love the stuff you guys did in the
mall because i don't think i've ever
seen a musical act
and maybe i'm wrong about this but i
don't remember a lot of musicals filming
in an actual mall
and doing what you guys did so what was
it like actually filming
in a mall i grew up on the east coast
malls are a whole thing with us
oh well i grew up in cincinnati ohio
malls are the
lifeblood um i do feel and it was i mean
it was fun because you're literally
like you're surrounded by the smells of
like the pretzel stand and like the
smoothie station and all the perfume and
so and it's also like a giant
mall where there are you know real
people just like shopping and going
about their day
and so you do you feel a little sneaky
like here we are
like making a movie like while other you
know while
people are just trying to live their
life but it was it was really fun
uh i love the song love thy neighbor
because it
it basically points out the hypocrisy in
the bible uh but there's a lot of great
songs in this
and i know it's a little generic but do
you have a favorite
oh my goodness i don't think i have a
favorite
i do i agree i love love thy neighbor i
think andrew reynolds
absolutely stops the show like he's
i mean it's it's fantastic and i will
say any number that has a lot of dancing
with our incredible
troupe of dancers is probably my
favorite because
everyone works so hard and the energy
and joy that they bring just like
leaps to life out of the screen uh how
many days did it take before you were
comfortable bringing up moulin rouge
with uh nicole
i actually i never fried it up
i tried to be you know as respectful as
possible and i don't i wasn't sure like
you know
if you know she wanted to talk about
that so we just talked about other
things instead and
uh yeah got it um did you guys create a
group text that you did together and
if so who sent too many
actually no group text surprisingly okay
that's very disappointing
um uh jumping backwards you obviously
had to come you had to prep
so much before filming began what was
the thing that maybe
this is your first you know big project
um what was the thing maybe you were
most nervous about
going in on those first few days of
filming
um 100
um talk about prep but playing the
guitar so i
i don't play and i had to learn how to
play for the song on really hard and
that was something that i had like
practiced a lot
but i also knew you know some nerves can
get in the way and you just never know
what's going to happen on the day of
filming so that was definitely the one
that i was
most nervous about and i think it's also
like the one that i'm i'm proudest of
how it turned out because i
had to work really hard to do it
completely i gotta go i'm just gonna say
again
congrats you did such a great job thank
you so much steven